hi I'm Luke Jamison I'm at BuzzFeed and
I'm here to read your thirst tweets
[Music]
first thirst tweet
Luke James got them let me bite you but
eyes you know I've been known to bite
some booty you know these you know it's
crazy
Luke James can put it on my buttons I
know how autocorrect works and I know
that all it's supposed to be something
crazy
when what what's all the butt jokes I
mean but stuff this is really nasty
there's nothing like really later on
when we make love
listen Luke James can sing me right out
of the panties I rarely wear oh wow okay
you rarely wear them you commando Luke
James skin is so smooth I just want to
lick his face I'm into it
don't be random though like we need to
be like having a great conversation
inside the moment and then it happens
not some creepiness like I hug you and
also like face you know I say mr. eyes I
do um shea butter Noah aka Luke James
can get this face ride with his fine
self crying laughing sad face sad face
Oh
hashtag star on Fox you lucky I'm down
with the shit's okay you come online I
don't get it
hydraulics and all you Billy put your
ass in a coma I got my Invisalign in -
you ready y'all do not see where B
iodine's everybody oh I wonder how Luke
James lips feel I wonder - cuz I love me
you know sometimes I gotta kiss myself
they feel like home if that means
anything like a place you want to be
where you belong luckily my mom don't
like to get on the internet so I can say
all this [ __ ] I want to say get into it
I think everybody should do this every
morning
because it like make the world a better
place somebody wants you somebody wants
you to do ridiculous nasty filthy things
to them that's love in another kind of
way you have to see it that way that's
something for your morale you know right
now if I go get a job I haven't had a
celebrity crush
since I was a kid but Luke James ass man
he a full meal at my favorite restaurant
I like that thank you
eat me up all right my confidence is on
another level right now this feels good
drugs
Luke James can do what he want with my
body you damn right I'm gonna do it I
won't pretzel your ass you know I don't
know this is crazy
I want to eat Luke jay-z's ass okay I'm
weirded I'm with it I'm well-kept I'm a
clean sucker
anybody said anyone have a baby I'm
trying to bring some love into the world
nobody want to just be here stay with me
I just want to do things and get away
nobody say they won't stay Luke James is
pure sex yes I am that's a little people
think that of you cuz I don't really see
that of myself I am here for every piece
of Luke James's body and voice every
damn piece so everything about me that
was close to what I'm looking for
Luke James can sing one note and have
you wet in the drawers yes yes I can
forecast soggy hey fellas come to my
show bring your rag coat go it down baby
okay but only if she wants to don't be
no Punk all right I want Luke James to
put twins in me see I've been waiting
I've been waiting for somebody they want
to have a baby with me twins no that's a
lot I need let me stop work because you
go to it that's hard that's a whole
nother thing there life two at one time
okay I'll try
I think I have to be on top of that I
heard that's kind of loud
I've now experienced a full-body orgasm
after that performance thanks Luke James
told you I could do it and all of that I
make love to make more love and that is
what it is children that's what we all
need today the world would be a better
place if everyone were to try to make a
love with people who love you I really
appreciate all of you thank you so much
buzzfeed that really did something well
to my morale and I feel loved and all
the right places
-
it's called go girl feel good about
yourself go girl
album coming January 2020 I'm Luke James
this is BuzzFeed 30 streets we have
thank you so much